قبل ساعات من الاقلاع بمطار جون كندي في
نيويورك تم الامساك بحمزه احمد من قبل
عملاء
فيدراليين وقال مسؤول ان حمزه ارتاد حافله
من منيابولس للسفر بطائره الى تركيا بنيه
قاتله ووجهت له تهمه محاوله الانضمام الى
داعش للمقاتله بجانب الارهابيين ولم يعلق
محامي احمد بينما قال مسؤول ان حمزه نشر
هذه التغريدات قائلا انه اراد ان يكون
جهاديا وشهيدا احمد هو امريكي من اصل
صومالي ويعيش في منيابولس وقال محام في
المدينه لشبكتنا ان احمد يمثل تغيرا خطيرا
لتجنيد
الارهابيين الشباب هي مجموعه وحشيه في
الصومال تابعه للقاعده وجندت سابقا اكثر
من 20 امريكي من اصل صومالي في مينيسوتا
للقتال معهم احدهم كان جمال بنا طالب
هندسه جامعي وبعد اختفائه فجاه من المنزل
شاهدت عائلته صوره له على الانترنت بعد
فتره وهو مقتول برصاصه استقرت في راسه
باحد شوارع مقديشو بينما لا يزال الاحباط
يسيطر على قاده صوماليين قائلين انهم
يفقدون شبابهم بشكل مستمر والسبب يعود الى
قله الفرص وضعف الهويه بحسب ما قال قاده
المجتمع حيث ان الشباب ممزق بين بلدين فهم
امريكيون لكنهم لا يشعرون بانهم متقبل
كمواطنين هناك اضافه الى كون اغلبهم من
ميتمي
ويتمثل القلق الان فيما قد يحدث عند عوده
هؤلاء الشباب الامريكيين الى الولايات
المتحده